[Music]
so in yet another year of high inflation
expected low growth and gen generally
economic turbulence how does one Take
Back Control their finances and their
wealth in these times of uncertainty to
discuss all this and more I'm joined by
two experts in the field Charlotte
Lambeth is director of private clients
at Charles Stanley and Martin Vander
Ware is the business editor The
Spectator welcome both
well let's Jump Right In Charlotte what
are some of the more worrying Trends
you're seeing and that you've noticed in
light of the cost of living crisis what
is it that your clients are telling you
where is there increased anxiety when it
comes to the protection of wealth and
management of wealth for clients at
Charles Stanley
well
Charles Stanley very much Prides itself
on providing a personal service to
clients and say we like to stay on top
of what what is concerning them so
actually we we did some research in the
last couple of months where we were
talking to
behind net worth individuals and and
clients to see what they were thinking
about various things and I think some of
the key themes that came out for them of
being concerned at the moment perhaps
unsurprisingly was what's going on with
inflation uh how they're going to
provide income particularly in
retirement
and what investment returns might look
like going forward given the rather
difficult period that we've been through
recently Martin can you give us a sense
of the current economic climate I mean I
think a lot of people tuning in today
will know that it's not great but you
know give us some detail around that and
how it's impacting people's attitudes
towards their Investments
yes well aware
we're in a phase which is
very unfamiliar to anyone who wasn't
already an adult either you know in the
mid 1970s or early 1980s I.E a period of
sharp inflation and that is very
disconcerting I think particularly for
people
at or approaching retirement because
fairly obviously incomes
and especially the retirement income
people may have foreseen or arranged for
themselves are not generally index
leaked and are not going up in line with
inflation but costs have suddenly jumped
so I think inflation is the biggest
issue on the table in front of us low
growth which you alluded to is a problem
you know there are a whole set of
problems in the UK economy low
productivity and so on all of those feed
through probably into low investment
Returns on Equity portfolios in the long
run but that's a that's a different
issue
um right now
inflation is the worry it is beginning
to Peak it may have peaked around 11
generally but it's higher than that
clearly for energy and food of course it
may come down again Rishi sunak I think
promised to halve it by the end of the
year it's really nothing to do with him
but it may have it it may halve Itself
by the end of the year it may kind of
have gone back to what we consider
normal which is you know the bank of
England's target range or a two two and
a half percent it may get back there you
know sometime next year but having done
that prices will still have gone up by a
significant Notch so the the
relationship between a relatively fixed
income that we may have planned for our
retirement and what it actually costs to
live will have altered permanently by
that so so I think that's an absolutely
core issue for us to talk about today we
certainly will before we get into all
those details Charlotte in the next hour
we want to broker Focus broadly on
investment management in the session can
you tell us how that fits into the
framework of financial planning yeah
sure so I am an investment manager I've
been doing it for the better part of
well 25 years last year
um so I've been doing it for a while but
my role is very much fitting in with
other advisors for clients and in
particular financial planners so their
role is to think about the clients
overall position and in particular to
work out what products and wrappers are
going to help them meet their goals so
that might be things like a pension for
retirement planning it might be life
insurance type things or an offshore
Bond or inheritance taxpaying that type
of thing but once those pots have been
identified
my job is then for any of those that
might need to be invested to come up
with an appropriate strategy for those
to make sure that it's going to meet its
goal going forward so whatever time
frame it's got any particular
requirements tax issues all those sorts
of concerns my goal is then to do the
day-to-day buying and selling to make it
do that over time so then I'm constantly
checking in with both the client and the
financial planner to make sure that the
whole thing's still fitting together and
the strategy still works Martin a very
important piece of the puzzle yeah
well I'm sure you know on the top of
Charlotte's sort of blotter in every
client meeting would be kyc know your
customer actually what I'd say is the
customer the the the the uh impending
retiree whatever your age know your own
circumstances is absolutely essential to
this what I mean by that is is
that we all have to learn to take a sort
of holistic
view
uh what will my outgoings add up to
over the next few years what could my
income add up to what would I like it to
be how much might I want to pass
to my children or should I hang on to it
or should I spend it all on cruise
holidays you know
um these are not trivial questions in
the sense that anything you do with your
money depends on what you want the
result to be and how you want to live do
I live in a house that's much bigger
than I need how expensive would it be to
go through all the turmoil of you know
trading down to a smaller house these
are these are questions that need to be
addressed and the the investment portion
is is a piece of that jigsaw if you want
a metaphor for current circumstances one
that that I do if this is a metaphor or
not but anyway it's a vivid example I
would say reprogram your central heating
boiler what do I mean by that you may be
running energy costs much higher than
you need to when did you last look at
the little gadget on the boiler to see
if you could reduce it I did that I
think I'd probably saved myself a
thousand pounds a year wow and that's
just one of many many things people
should think of to create a whole
picture what they own what it can
generate for them what their
entitlements are and so on and then how
to manage the Investments that are in
there somewhere and Charlotte if the
role of investment management is done
correctly how can that help to alleviate
risk
so risk is absolutely Central to
everything that I do it I get very
boring talking to clients about risk
because it really is the Cornerstone for
what I'm doing we're tuning in for it so
don't matter all you want so I suppose
there's two key elements to risk that I
want to understand from a client first
of all
um one is how much risk can they afford
to take so actually given their
circumstances what happens if if one of
those pots of money that I talked about
earlier does go particularly down I have
to admit clients generally are quite
happy for it to go up as much as it
likes but it's always on the downside
that I get calls so you know that's what
I tend to talk about
um so we need to understand what what
happens you know is it just the fact
that they feel bad when they get their
valuation is it the fact they can't have
that extra ski holiday or does it impact
the gas bill getting paid you know how
critical is it so there's the the
Financial Risk tolerance but then
there's also the emotion additional risk
tolerance because different people feel
very differently about how things
um you know feel when it when they're
going up and down when when you turn on
the news and you get that lovely little
chart that they tend to put on the
picture with the red line sort of
shooting downwards and you get news that
the Fitzy's had a bad day do you just
kind of go oh fine and move on or
actually does that mean you're suddenly
struggling to get to sleep that night
because you're worried about what's
happening
um and the two things are not quite the
same just because you can take risk
doesn't mean you're comfortable doing it
and sometimes people might be very
comfortable with the idea of it but I
have to encourage them not to because
actually it wouldn't be sensible in
their overall circumstances that's a
such an interesting point that sort of
emotional toll that it can take and you
know I'm not a homeowner yet I hope to
be one day but I have quite a lot of
friends that are and you know they've
been weighing up whether to get a fixed
term mortgage and within interest rates
doing what they're doing you know it
feels for a lot of them like an
emotional decision and are they going to
be able to handle it if interest rates
are going up or down the disappointment
the frustration that they might feel
around that absolutely and weighing up
on the one hand the does it feel good to
have the consistency you know at least
if you go down the fixed route you know
exactly what you're getting into for a
period of time does that give you a high
level of reassurance or if we were to
find the interest rates Peak soon and
actually over a five-year term perhaps
actually during that time interest rates
go back down again would they be feeling
really frustrated that they're missing
out on on that downward trajectory
different people are going to approach
that very differently and part of our
job is very much trying to get under
their skin initially to understand how
they feel about missing out on a
opportunity versus protecting themselves
from a negative
period but Martin in times of economic
turbulence these are very difficult
calls for even investment manager to
make I mean in 2019 nobody could have
predicted what was going to happen to
the supermarkets and you know their huge
profits in 2020 for external factors and
uh you know 2020 you wouldn't have
predicted where Energy prices would be
now because of completely external
factors
um how does one go about managing this
well you can only act upon what you know
now is it well you can't you can't
provide for all possible changes of
circumstances it's
um
probably unwise
to react to short-term changes in a you
know in a very energetic dramatic way in
relation to your portfolio of assets
um so you have to kind of be calm enough
to ride out the surprises I think
um
I'm sure Charlotte does this but
whenever I've ever talked to her a
wealth manager they always say do you
think your high medium or low risk and I
always think I'm sort of medium to low
I'm not a natural risk taker I don't
expect a managed portfolio to do much
more than track the indices over a long
period of time if your money does that
after you've paid the fees and the you
know the size of the fees is an
important factor in that then you've
done okay you've you know if if you are
a bit more of a risk taker well you may
have a separate pot that you do the risk
stuff with but your core savings you
should
uh not panic in the short term take a
long-term view in which you you want a
reasonable return but you're not
expecting something spectacular and you
don't want your manager to lose your
Capital that's where it goes you want to
pay a modest fee you want all the tax
advantages you can have around that and
those are the important things but but
staying calm when circumstances change
the moments one can now recall when
circumstances really change if we think
back to 2008 there was a really you know
a moment of existential crisis then
where people thought my goodness my
savings will be wiped out the ATM will
stop working tonight you know what I
mean well we kind of came through that
you know two or three years later it
didn't look so bad in hindsight we've
come through covid we're coming through
this inflation Spike so that may sound a
bit Bland but I think you have to take a
medium to long term view of all of this
stuff Don't Panic as they
and Martin you're picking up on an
important theme there and I'll put this
to you Charlotte about expectation what
are reasonable expectations when people
are looking at Investment Management
right now
does depend on the level of risk that
they're prepared to take obviously the
the lower the risk the lower the return
um but can anybody at the moment really
win at the inflation game I mean it it
feels like perhaps some expectations
specifically at the moment might be
slightly out of touch with reality if
someone was to say to me with us with
double-digit inflation can I get an
investment that's going to if a sensible
risk outperform inflation and give me
growth above that for practical terms
I'm going to say no no you can't
um because with the best one in the
world even with interest rates having
risen considerably from where they've
been for the last 15 years
um we're still only in a sort of four
percent type zone for sort of interest
rates and so on and Equity returns are
going to use that as a a base
um and when they're looking at dividends
and so on how much they reward investors
for taking the risk of of going with
with a shareholding rather than a
slightly safer investment um you know
bears that in mind but you're still not
going to be looking at anything that's
going to get close to to a 10 plus
percent return on on that
um now I'm not saying that there's no
holding out there that that isn't going
to do that but as an overall portfolio
it's not reasonable so I mean I suppose
medium-term expectations at the minute
we would say maybe fixed interest
markets Total return four to five
percent equity markets maybe six seven
percent something like that might be
reasonable but of course when you're
building a portfolio you're putting
together a basket of different assets so
you will have some that have lower
returns some that have higher returns
but trying to smooth the the ups and
downs that intrinsically go with all of
those different type
Martin do you agree people have to
manage their expectations as well as
their actual Investments yes I do so
clearly to aim for the the set of
Investments That might beat the current
rate of inflation you're going to place
yourself in the high risk category we
can talk about what those kind of things
might be
um so
a sensible expectation for the time
being was you might be undershooting
inflation if you're not taking too much
risk there are choices there are always
choices so a choice that would again be
presented to you by you know any wealth
manager meeting a client would be what
is it what's your ethical choices for
example if you want to you know a
Greener and cleaner and no defense
stocks and no no carbon energy stocks in
your portfolio you're probably
um settling for a lower returns right
now than if you opened that door that's
a difficult you know moral question to
face but actually if you want higher
returns at the moment
big energy Big Oil those sort of things
are producing spectacular returns so
there are some difficult questions to be
to be faced but there are there are
choices if you want to make them well I
want to get into the details of that but
first want to remind people who are
watching from the office or at home that
you can submit a question to Charlotte
or Martin there's a little box right
below your screen you can submit a
question it goes straight to the
spectator TV and it comes straight to me
and some are already coming in which is
fantastic I already have a fairly long
list here but we'll hopefully have have
room for quite a few questions so please
do submit those
um so Charlotte on on that point that
Martin's made about you know you're
making choices you're making risk
decisions you're making ethical
decisions what are the investment
opportunities at the moment um you know
give us an understanding of sort of
where you are looking to when it comes
to where you might be thinking about
some of those bigger returns
so we're generally looking medium term
out there I'm not trying to day trade my
way through things so we're looking at
themes that feel comfortable at the
minute
um some of those are probably getting
quite a lot of press at the moment I I
would be saying that they're is interest
to be had in in the green energy space
at the moment clearly there's a lot of
government regulation and support uh
coming through to encourage movements in
that direction as well as I suppose just
the Zeitgeist if you like I think people
are feeling more
um willing to want to try and move in
that direction so um there is support
there having said that we're not the
only people to have noticed um there's
been a lot of pressure on those types of
Investments I think one does need to be
careful in how you try and
um access those kind of areas
um similarly I think
um things like digital uh as a general
theme perhaps has been given a bit of a
Turbo Charge by covert and the pandemic
over the last couple of years clearly
the internet was a a big change to life
over the last few years anyway but I
think it's really forced all of us to do
even more online perhaps than we were
before whether that's meetings and and
virtual spaces as far as that's
concerned or just what we expect from
the websites that we visit you know I
think we anticipate that our ability to
transact or interact with businesses has
massively increased over that period but
that comes with cyber security issues it
comes with storage issues so you know
perhaps that's the cloud maybe coming
into that Etc so lots of areas in in the
digital space and I think another theme
that we're very much looking at is
deglobalization the the shortening of
supply lines and that sort of thing
which we've very much seen again the the
pandemic perhaps highlighted the risks
of of everything being outsourced to
China or the Far East and suddenly you
you can't get at things or
um it's it's harder to have control over
it so we're seeing businesses looking at
trying to bring production uh closer to
home
um but that often comes with increasing
costs so then they're thinking about how
they can tackle that and I would say
things like Robotics and Ai and that
kind of thing is a way that businesses
can consider reducing costs while still
meeting that sort of bring it home uh
thought process on production so those
are some of the key areas we're looking
at at the moment Martin what sectors are
you looking at
well I wrote recently in my column
I invited readers to suggest
value stocks that you could you know
tuck away and not worry about and that
were kind of undervalued and and we
produced a list and it did actually
outperform the ftse 100 it was things
like Barrett the house Builder house
builders have been doing quite well you
can never really go wrong with you
mentioned big supermarkets but you know
those are fantastically well-managed
businesses that you know
um come through all changes of
circumstances very strongly and so
anyway looking for Value
undervalued solid safe stocks it's a
good approach I noted however that uh
Although our reader portfolio had beaten
the footsie by a narrow margin they were
we would have done much better to put
our money into meta the parent of
Facebook or Tesla both of which had a
having had a huge fall had a big
Resurgence but there you are there's
there we are looking at risk again you
know U.S tech stocks have been in the
hottest thing ever for the last few
years could it go on forever people said
it couldn't they fell now they're
recovering a bit if you're looking at if
you're looking at this from a UK
perspective yet another question your
wealth manager is bound to ask you is
how tolerant would you be of a sort of
globalized portfolio you know do you
want a piece that's in Emerging Markets
or you know how happy are you with
Europe America and the UK a lot of fund
managers I'd love to hear what Charlotte
says about this that really have quite
small portions in the UK even for the
sort of middle of the road starter
portfolio you sometimes see surprisingly
little in UK equities which is a
reflection I'm afraid
where the UK is and the US is much more
exciting and if you're a bit braver
Emerging Markets Asia and so on more
exciting still it's
it's just over the last few years I
think there was a time when
um investors expected to see quite a big
chunk in the UK and partially there's a
thing around currency risk in that you
know the idea of investing in your
domestic Market because if your
liabilities are in Pounds Sterling it
makes sense to hold your investments in
pound sterling but you're absolutely
right you know the the UK Market's not
necessarily given you the returns that
you want over quite some time so
actually it's made sense to to broaden
your reach and the US in particular has
very much been leading the way for for
quite some time now much shorter term
actually the ftse 100 in particular last
year did pretty well because we have
such a high waiting in energy stocks and
actually compared to the US where
they've got a big Tech waiting they had
a rougher time of it last year actually
the likes of BP and shell and so on
really did mean that the ftse 100 looked
pretty positive in 2022
compared to other regions so these
things Urban
um I think the nice thing about being
investor whenever you're considering
things and particularly in a time where
things feel perhaps challenging and
difficult when we're living through the
cost of living crisis is that actually
first of all markets look ahead so
actually you're not looking at what's
going on right now you're looking at
what's going to happen in the future and
secondly you can be much more Fleet of
fit so whilst we're living here in the
UK and most of us aren't going to
suddenly decide that actually if we
don't like it we're literally going to
relocate somewhere else I mean a few
maybe will but you know most of us have
got reasons to be here as an investor
that's not quite the same so actually if
I don't like the UK at a period And I
think there are other opportunities I
can just say well fine we will reduce
that waiting we'll go somewhere else so
you don't have to be somewhere that you
really don't think
is is a good place and that really
brings us on to political economy Martin
and you know they say businesses hate
uncertainty but investors don't love it
either and there could potentially be
some very big changes coming up in the
UK
um that affect the economy not least
potentially change of government and
leadership in the next 18 months can
investors should investors in any way be
factoring in what a labor government
could mean
um I don't know I don't really know how
you factor it in but what what
difference would a labor government make
so
well this is a very huge difference
between the two parties so for example
taxes we might expect to remain high
might even get higher personal taxes
um corporate taxes which we could enter
into a whole debate about but uh you
know Beginning to Look sort of
punishingly high even under this
conservative government when the next
Rising corporation tax goes through
that's very unlikely to be reversed too
so as a competitive economy we're not
going to be looking any better under a
labor government however I think history
says that the stock market doesn't do
too badly under labor governments for
for some reason the stock markets look
forward maybe they look forward to the
fall of the labor government I don't
know what it is but history doesn't say
that every time there's a labor
government stock markets
um it come thundering down
um so one would expect a more
uh well limited growth prospects
certainly High tax regime certainly
where interest rates are going we don't
really know but we do expect them to
Peak in terms of official interest rates
going up in notches we think we're near
the peak of that so they may come down a
little bit but a realistic expectation
would be interest rates will stay higher
than they were in the previous decade
when they were unnaturally low they will
stay up in the somewhere three three
four percent there for some time but
that's not bad for Savers that gives you
a little income on your deposit account
whereas for a long time you had no
income at all so I'd say Don't Panic
again at the prospect of a labor
government but I don't think it'll
improve the state of the economy but it
it it shouldn't explode the stock market
we're just nearing the 30 minute Mark
and I'm going to move to questions in a
minute we have loads coming in which is
fantastic I'm going to abuse my position
as chair to ask you to a few more
questions but just remember remember
that you can submit a question as well
there's a small box underneath
underneath the screen where you're
watching this and you can submit a
question it comes to The Spectator team
and directly to me so I can hopefully
put that to Charlotte and Martin
um Charlotte I'd like to ask you when
your clients come in is there any common
theme about what they are investing for
um is there a common motivation is it
about personal use of these funds is it
about passing wealth On to the Next
Generation
so it does vary hugely but I think
probably the the key themes that we hear
time and again would be
investing for later life so retirement
and maintaining a lifestyle in in
retirement covering care costs that's
certainly something that people worry
about these days quite a lot
um but also I think that point about
Legacy passing on to the next generation
is also something that people are quite
often Keen to try and ensure and so our
role is very much trying to balance
making sure that they've got enough to
achieve all of those goals for their
lifetime whilst also doing what we can
to set things up in a way that's going
to be efficient and will allow them to
pass it on in a reasonable fashion as
well uh Marcin do you think there's
sometimes a problem with how we talk to
um people and and actually specifically
how people sometimes talk to their
children about money I noticed that in
Charles Stanley's research they found
that 58 of people don't feel comfortable
discussing money with children if you
don't have those conversations how can
you set them up for success
well quite quite so and um well Silas
and I were just chatting beforehand
about this and comparing the point of
view where you you might say to your
children well look I've brought you up
you've had a good education you've had a
good home I've taught you good manners
I've taught you common sense that's it
you're on your own or the further stage
really is to be more of a worried parent
as it were I think of the example of a
friend of mine who decided he wouldn't
retire until each of his children he had
three of them owned a small flat in some
outer zone of the London transport map
and the beginning of a pension part so
he worked into his late 60s and he
achieved that for three children uh or I
think all one can say is
wouldn't it be good to launch your the
Next Generation into the world with some
degree of you know Financial Security
helping them buy a first home being the
most obvious of those
if you can but as Charlotte says your
own circumstances in late late life in
your 80s and 90s can become very very
expensive so no one no no one should as
it were empty their coffers for the sake
of the children who have a you know a
Fighting Chance in life to get on with
it if that means they themselves
can't afford the care they need in later
life so it's a diff very difficult to
judge that but I think it's admirable to
try and get your children on the at
least on the property ladder and early
rather than late really otherwise
they're just going to stay at home and
be a damn nuisance to you into their 30s
and 40s who knows Charlotte another
statistic
prize was that just over a third of high
net wealth individuals say they are
currently helping a partner with the
cost of living crisis or or a quarter
are helping their children I actually I
say I was surprised I probably shouldn't
be surprised by that but it is quite
shocking
um statistic are you finding that
clients are selling up because they need
to meet the cost of bills they need to
meet the cost of food
it's not ex I wouldn't say it's exactly
about the cost of bills and the cost of
feed but I think we are definitely
seeing
um Trends where people are saying look
if I can maybe pass some money down to
say adult children in order to enable
them to reduce a mortgage or something
like that so that you can take some of
the strain off
um
the day-to-day for them
hopefully in a way that's also putting
them in a better position longer term I
think there's often a thought process
that feels like it's nice to do
something that feels
like it's really moving someone's
financial position forward if you see
what I mean for the future
um but definitely I think the current
climate is encouraging people to do
something now rather than thinking well
yeah maybe I'll help them with that in a
few years time or when I die they'll get
some money and they can use it for that
they're sort of saying no there's a need
right now and actually I want to I want
to act on that
well the last question I have for both
of you is um in theory a very simple
question but I'm not sure it is is now a
good time to invest Martin
there's never a bad time to invest okay
and it's never sensible to just sit on a
pile of cash
uh that would be my starting point for
that and of course you don't know we
don't know where the stock market's
going
um we as I've said we probably do sort
of know where interest rates are going
for the next couple of years but to do
nothing is really foolish to arrange
your portfolio of Assets in the way that
you think is going to optimize your
circumstances and give you security for
the medium to long term should be an
objective for everyone so but that may
sound uh
too simplistic but I would say it's
there's never a time when you shouldn't
be thinking about investing or arranging
your assets as best you can no that
makes complete sense to me but Charlotte
some people might be nervous about these
turbulent times that we're in to think
to themselves oh is this really the
moment that I should take a gamble is
this really the moment that I take my
cash and invest it oh do you agree with
Mars
I mean obviously if you jump in right at
the top of a market and then watch it go
down it's not going to feel great so I
appreciate why people are perhaps
concerned that the fear of missing out
is is
um strong but I would absolutely agree
first of all that doing nothing is
Frozen in headlights is is not going to
be the right answer first of all if you
make sure that your assets are arranged
appropriately you may well be able to
achieve tax efficiencies so even if um
the Returns on investment are quite low
on or relatively static you're
potentially saving 20 40 or whatever it
might be in tax well you know you try
and get a 20 return or a 40 return on
something actually making sure that
things are efficiently organized can
still put you in a much better situation
I think the other thing is thinking
about time frames
um yeah maybe over the first few months
something you might find that it doesn't
quite work out but really investing is
something that you should be doing with
a long-term time frame in mind you know
at least sort of five years or so and
actually in all likelihood things will
shake out in the wash a bit over that
time so
um you know I always think that managing
Investments or being a client with
Investments it's a bit like dieting you
don't get on the scales every day you
know kind of you put it in you do the
work and eventually you would expect to
get the results
and we're going to move into questions
there's so many coming in thank you for
that and just another reminder that if
you have another question you'd like to
ask or if you are holding back on asking
a question just pop it in the box right
below your screen send it on over and
they'll come straight to me
um so we have some really good questions
coming in Charlotte and Martin and
there's a very common theme that I've
picked up on which is Cash A lot of
people are asking how much money should
they keep in cash when it comes to
figuring out where they're going to
invest Martin
well I'm glad we've moved off dieting
how much should you keep in cash
well uh what can I say if you if you
have plenty of cash to start with you
might say it would be sensible to keep
three to six months worth of running
expenses in cash on a deposit account in
case of some you know
mishap the roof Falls in you know the
insurance doesn't pay out whatever it is
uh your child comes home and says they
desperately need ten thousand pounds to
you know fulfill their lifetime ambition
whatever so but beyond that kind of a
reserve for something that might happen
in your domestic life that you just need
cash for uh don't sit on cash as my
general don't sit on much Charlotte
will certainly cash is an important part
of the equation we'd never be suggesting
that people don't have any at all there
are times when it might make sense to
have a bit more there if people have got
something on the radar that they're
potentially thinking might might be
required so again sometimes clients will
say to me I'm thinking that I I want to
buy a house in the next 12 to 18 months
but can I do something with the money
I've got saved for the deposit frankly
I'd be really nervous about trying to
invest something like that over that
sort of time Horizon there's too much
chance that things go against you and
then the deposit you've got is going to
be worth a lot less that that would be
problematic so in those kind of
circumstances do the best you can within
the cash environment you know seek out a
term deposit maybe that would sit your
time frame or suit your time frame and
give you a bit more or something like
that but absolutely with inflation at 10
percent
even with interest rates having picked
up a bit there is no way that the value
of that cash isn't going backwards in
real terms at the moment and yes we've
said that you you're not necessarily
going to be beating inflation and
Investments but you've got far more
chance of getting something a bit closer
and certainly over longer term time
Horizons you've got more chance of of
beating inflation
um by being outside of cash so it's got
a place but it's part of an overall
package Charlotte someone's asked how
often people should be rebalancing their
portfolios how often would you recommend
to your clients that they switch things
up well it is a really tricky one
um we're reviewing things
in a few different ways so on the one
hand we're looking at things every day
from the point of view of the news flow
on any particular stock or something
that might change our view so that could
happen at any time
but the point where you stand back and
look at the whole thing and kind of
think okay what's ended up a bit
overweight what's ended up a bit
underweight what do I need to juggle
around
you don't want to do that too frequently
because markets are moving every day
it's never going to stay looking perfect
Beyond
the market close at 4pm 4 30. so
um
we would normally look at something say
quarterly half yearly with that big kind
of overview again
um it's I'd say it's a bit like
gardening you plant your border up and
things grow and you know you have to get
in and prune it from time to time you
need to do the day-to-day weeding but
you're not literally ripping the whole
thing out and starting again on a very
frequent basis Martin would you have any
ideas or recommendations around
reassessing one's portfolio well well if
you are the sort of person who enjoys
following markets and looking at
um share prices every day then
uh you may get a cake and a better
result out of out of doing just that and
I you know know people who sit at home
in their retirement years basically
playing the stock market but but that's
a particular personality type enjoy it
and they enjoy it they love it and they
do it consistently so they don't ease
off you know uh and the problem is if
you're going to do it that way you've
got to keep doing it that way most
people I think would much rather not
need to do that and and don't have the
inclination or feel they have the talent
to do it so it's much better to allow a
manager to do it for you and you don't
want a portfolio that's been constantly
churned because that implies quite a lot
of fees and transaction costs and
margins between buy and sell and so on
and so there are some of the great
investors of the world and the likes of
Warren Buffett as it were by a big thing
every now and then and sit on it for 20
years and do very well and you know we
should keep those examples in mind
Martin um we have a few questions about
um you you said you know
try to avoid the the the desire to go
for the short term and look at the
medium to the long term a few people are
asking well is there any credibility in
just following the trends can you can
you do well out of that cryptocurrency
is the main example that we're getting
in the questions is that a Savvy
investment one person asks
uh well new but then it's not really an
investment it's a gambling chip let's
distinguish between things you can take
a punt on and they might dramatically go
up in the short term or they might wipe
themselves out all together I mean it
will have been very tempting in these
last few years to have a go on um uh
cryptocurrencies and when I ask a
question in The Spectator offices the
other day how many of you all the young
people said they'd had a dapple uh
whereas I don't know any people of my
age who are dabbling in it at all but
it's not an investment category as such
it's a it's an interesting possibly
exciting gambling chip so let's
distinguish between highly volatile
things that are out there that you can
buy and sell which are for the pot of
money that's you know you can really
afford to lose but you might just double
it if you're lucky that's one end of
your asset portfolio but it ought to be
rather a small piece of the total
portfolio and it's a Gamble Charlotte
you're nodding along
um no I would agree we we don't regard
crypto as an investment yet
um it's not it's not there yet I'm not
maybe it will be one day
um but but not at the moment
um it's not regulated really you haven't
got any Protections in in that and one
thing that we've seen recently is this
trend towards the fact that um I mean
some of its Advocates will regard that
as a positive the fact that it's taking
you outside of some of the systems that
they might might suggest are broken or
dysfunctional
um but the problem is it's it's not
necessarily giving you something that
you can rely on we've seen obviously
some some failures in in some of those
exchanges and one thing that's
interesting is how Regulators are saying
look you might not be formally regulated
in exactly the way that other
Investments are that doesn't mean you're
outside the law and so actually again
we've seen
um action taken particularly in the US
which is curbing the way that they're
able to operate and if you were
investing in them might be causing you
some some problems and difficulties so I
would absolutely agree at the minute if
you've got a little bit that you really
don't mind if it totally goes you know
treat it like going to the horses and
have some fun and fine but it's it's
that kind of approach uh Martin somebody
asks is property still King
especially with the talk of house prices
potentially tanking
well a roof over your head is clearly
um an essential of life and a
fundamental part of most people's asset
portfolio by the time they reach the age
where they're looking towards retirement
so your own home
is
um has a special
category of value as it were in any sort
of discussion like this is property
going to go up again it's coming down
slightly at the moment there's been talk
of a a plunge of falling off a cliff and
so on uh some real Dooms to stuff but
that doesn't quite seem to be happening
but the fact is for six or seven months
property prices have been notching
downwards they may continue to do that
through this year they will in due
course begin to recover again so as a
long-term asset property uh or you can't
really go wrong and you need somewhere
to live and if you can reach the stage
in later life where you're unmortgaged
you own your own home that is an element
of personal security which is you know
enormously valuable is buy to let
property on the other hand
um is nowadays
looks are much less attractive
proposition and it's kind of gone out of
fashion the tax treatment of rental
income isn't favorable
and the you know as property prices are
going down the possibility of a capital
gain on your by to let has gone away for
the time being so I would say now
probably isn't the moment to be going
into vitalet but now is always a moment
for owning your own home and preferably
reaching the point where you're
unmortgaged by the time you retire
for an ordinary person with a few
savings
it's all about risk in the first
instance what what are your goals and
what are you trying to achieve and how
much risk are you prepared to take to
get there so um once you've thought
about those things if you decide that
you could tie some money up for a bit
and it's money that you could afford to
see go up and down in value because
let's face it Investments are always
going to be taking some some chance of
that happening
if you're talking relatively small
amounts I'd suggest that looking at some
form of collective investment scheme is
probably going to be a good place to
start so the likes of unit trusts and
weeks those kind of things because they
give you the chance to buy a fund that
then has a lot of different Holdings
underneath so you get to diversify your
risk in a way that you can't with your
your bit of money that you've got
available to you but again even within
that making sure that you're doing it
through an appropriate
wrapper or product if you haven't used
your Isa subscription then why not put
put some money into an issue any gains
and income will be tax-free again it
just means that that investment's going
to be working that little bit harder for
you because it's not being eroded by by
taxes along the way so
um that would perhaps be a good place to
to start for someone looking at the the
early stages
uh just a reminder to our audience that
we have
um just under 15 minutes left so do
submit your questions in the little box
below the screen and they'll come
straight to me and I'll I'll try to get
them in we do have a lot here to go
through still
um Charlotte someone's ass is now a good
time to buy guilts the guilt Market was
a very political topic actually over the
past few months
um with our former prime minister
um what's happening in the market now
and do you recommend it as a decent
investment well
um I mean yes October was a fascinating
time
it really was
um and uh it was very interesting
because we suddenly found ourselves in a
situation where um yields picked up
dramatically from where they've been for
a really long time I I have colleagues
who've been uh working with me for for
10 years plus now I don't regard them as
being the newbies and yet they had not
seen interest rates at these levels they
hadn't seen guilts under par
um you know it was all suddenly looking
very different and making me feel very
old
um they certainly look more interesting
than they have done for quite a long
time
um we've we've probably spent 15 years
saying that they just look very
expensive unless you've got very
particular requirements
um so they potentially have a place
again certainly the bond market
generally
um is is more on the radar perhaps than
it has been for for some time now you
can get returns that are noticeable you
can potentially see some some Capital
return as well as an income return from
that and of course bonds sit further
down the risk Spectrum than than
equities do they're not they're not as
safe as cash but they sit somewhere in
the middle again government guilts would
generally be regarded as being safer
than than corporate bonds and and then
you've got you know the big quality ones
versus the the junk ones and the high
risk end of things so it's all on a
spectrum but certainly I think fixed
income is is a place that's suddenly
back on the radar in a way that it
hasn't been for a really long time
Martin what do you think it's now the
time to buy guilt there are of course
some index linked guilds aren't there
but they've probably been priced
accordingly in current circumstances so
they now look very expensive don't they
index link is are a very specialist
beast and they don't always behave
exactly how you'd expect so they do
provide some inflation protection but
there are reasons why it's not automatic
that that it's just oh well you're fine
you don't need to worry about inflation
at 10 so yeah the conventionally any uh
sort of full-scale Investment Portfolio
would contain an element of bonds and I
think the short answers the Charlotte
says they've they look a bit more
attractive now than they were looking uh
when interest rates were absolutely at
Rock Bottom uh but I think you wouldn't
buy guilts as as it were as a vote of
confidence in UK governments in the UK
economy you might buy them just as a
building block of a of you know a fully
thought through portfolio
um Martin you were talking earlier
and you know the ethical questions
around that and somebody's written and
asking why are renewable energy stocks
not more Dynamic given all the concerns
around carbon fuels and War disruption
to oil and gas supplies
well we're in a short um we hope short
um crisis of energy Supply in which
Renewables have not Advanced to the
point that they can take up the it's
like they can fill the Gap filled by
shortages of of carbon energy Supply so
the value of big carbon energy suppliers
has gone up the attention paid to
Renewables uh businesses as
constantly gone down a bit that balance
will readjust itself
uh when let's hope we're beyond the
Ukraine war and normal circumstances
return to energy markets then I think
there will be a huge swing towards
Renewables so in a funny way now if
renewable the price of
the renewable Investments is relatively
low this might well be a good time to
buy them for the long term because for
sure by the end of this decade they will
be right in the in the spotlight but
just now the the world is dealing with a
short-term energy crisis to which the
only available answer is to use more
carbon fuel that's that's what's driving
prices in markets now Charlotte those
are some interesting ideas from Martin
there about long-term Investments is is
that broadly speaking the the take of
you and Charles Stanley that these are
potentially have big long-term payoff
but then of course there are so many
different kinds of renewable energy we
don't know at this point which one's
going to be truly Successful by the end
of the decade I I think that's
absolutely true
um it's such a fast-moving area isn't it
and I think we're not yet absolutely
sure what truly the the new energy of
the future is going to look like you
know is it going to be might not be
created yet oh exactly you know is is it
going to be hydrogen fuel cells is it
going to be you know nuclear is it going
to be um you know are we suddenly going
to run our cars on toothpaste who knows
you know um
um it's still a very fast developing
area and I think that's where
um you know the very high risk approach
would be looking at trying to find an
individual stock or two to to try and
hang your hat on
um we're generally taking an approach of
of a broader sweep and finding ways of
investing in the sector as a whole on
the basis that there's a lot of
relatively small companies out there all
trying their thing at the minute
um some of them will fall by the wayside
it won't work some of them may end up
being the new big big names of the
future whatever that might be and you're
hoping that you've you've got an in the
the relatively early stages with with
some of those
um but I think one has to accept that
trying trying to absolutely call it at
this stage is is very hard and pretty
high risk
the ideal investment for that might be
some collective vehicle an investment
trust or something that is
then in turn investing in a whole
portfolio of hydrogen wind solar you
know uh lithium battery Ventures some of
which will come through and do well but
you know what has actually happened uh
in the energy sector lately is that
the likes of shell and BP have been kind
of backpedaling from their renewable
investments in order to achieve a
re-rating of their shares to match how
you know Exxon and Chevron are
performing by not being so interested in
Renewables I mean it's a perverse
circumstance driven by the spike in the
underlying Energy prices but there is a
backing away from the Renewables actor
by Big Oil big energy companies so other
newer companies are going to have to
step into that Gap but picking them as
Charlotte says terribly difficult so if
you can find something that bundles them
and gives you more chances that will be
better and in absolutely
development in the in this area still
only they are piling in money to that
area at a much higher rate because of
course they've they've got the money
available in a way that a small startup
doesn't so it's an interesting area
um Martin there are quite a few
questions coming in about quantitative
easing
um someone says you know what can be
done to stop our governments from money
printing others say nothing can be done
to stop our governments from money
Printing and they're all leading to
questions about
um hard metals and gold and silver and
the extent to which they should play a
role in one's Investment Management what
do you make of that
um okay well the sort of easier part of
that is that gold at least has an
immensely long history of being a a
store of value that is that is portable
it's immutable it you know goes on
forever and so on so there is always
there are always people who are
enthusiasts for gold and gold in that
sense if you're looking for something
that isn't all this other stuff we're
talking about gold is a more sensible
thing than crypto by a mile
um
so yes there there will always be people
who are special enthusiasts for gold
it's not necessarily an obvious thing
for the general portfolio for the as it
were the the total amateur but but there
are it is proven long-term store of
value and it's counter cyclical if
everything else is going down gold is
often going up that's gold quantitative
easing well where are we with that will
it ever will they go on doing it is it a
very bad thing
um Kate you're more of an economist than
I am so you could offer a view too but
what we we are not seeing the unwinding
of the quantitative easing that's taken
place so far it probably has contributed
to inflation we many people always
thought it would do but it didn't to
begin with because there were
deflationary factors acting against it
that concealed its inflationary danger
now we probably recognize that it has
been part of this inflation Spike along
with the physical shortages we printed
more money in the first year of covert
in the UK than we did in the full 10
years leading up to that year when the
economy was shut down of course so yep
these factors came together in a very
inflationary way uh so I think
optimistically one would like to see an
end to unconventional monetary measures
just as one would like to see a return
to you know inflation at two percent and
interest rates that
um a comfortable rate that gives you a
return on your deposit account whether
we will I just don't know but I don't
think investors thinking about all these
you know asset allocation questions
we're talking about today should obsess
about quantitative easing it's not
something we can do do anything about
right you know work with the Practical
with the you know the circumstances
we're in
um Charlotte someone writes in to say
that they worry that so many people now
use tracker funds uh does this increase
potential risks of their use can you
talk us through tracker funds and what
they might be getting at here so um a
Tracker fund um mostly uh will be an
exchange traded fund an ETF or something
similar and it's designed to
um replicate an index of some
description so classic examples might be
the c100 or the S P 500 in in the US
and generally
um because they're you know you haven't
got a manager that's trying to make any
smart investment choices or anything
else they're literally just replicating
what's going on in that index it means
that the fees for investing in them are
usually pretty low so they're quite
cheap so if you are thinking that the
ftse 100 for example you know you you
think is a good place to be one way of
investing in that would be just buy a
Tracker fund and it gets you that
exposure quite cheaply
um that use has increased dramatically
um you know there's a lot of companies
now that have made it really their their
business to to provide these different
things and actually you can you can
almost gain exposure to anything I mean
you were mentioning things like
um ESG type Investments and green
Investments earlier and yes you can buy
trackers for lithium battery stocks or
you know this type of thing out there
now so there's some weird and wonderful
as well as
um uh you know much more conventional
um I think
it has changed the market
the nature of the tracker is worth
bearing in mind they're not all the same
some of them are constructed using the
actual physical assets underneath so
they they buy appropriate numbers of
shares in in the underlying others use
derivatives and that can give you
different exposures if the market moves
dramatically so it's worth understanding
how your tracker works
where I think it has made a difference
is
um actually in the performance of the
companies that are in an index because
it provides a layer of
support perhaps the share prices
um that wasn't there before because if
you're part of an index
you've naturally got a buyer in track of
funds that have to own your shares
whether you're doing well or not so that
perhaps provides a support but equally
at the margin if you're if you're the
company that is number 101 or you know
100 in in the ftse and you're perhaps
having a perfectly average year it's
it's not gone particularly well but it's
not gone particularly badly you're just
chuntering along but someone else has
come along and and
shot past you and gone into the index
and you're suddenly moving out
that's going to put selling pressure on
your shares so it's going to suddenly
move your price but without that really
reflecting the fundamentals of your
business so I think at the margin both
positive and negative it can create some
odd movements for individual companies
and also it can perhaps mask the the
underlying in in firms that are perhaps
a bit more solid in a ninja so there's
some issues there
um my last question to both of you and
uh it's just 1 pm so I'll ask for brief
answers if that's all right but a
reoccurring theme in these questions is
just you know these are very difficult
times you know what do you suggest I do
particularly in regards to inflation and
so you know if you had to give a top tip
really in managing these very difficult
times and managing inflation at over 10
percent Martin what do you think that
would be
um I think the top tip is more on the
side of as it were household management
than investment that is to say know
exactly what your outgoings are and how
you can control them more tightly than
you did before I think will will be a
more effective tool against inflation
than trying to juggle your Investments
because for the reasons we've said
you'll be jolly lucky to find something
that beats a 10 or 11 inflation rate but
you may well find in the way that your
life is organized there are things you
can cut costs on and your quality of
life is not is not diminished so I would
look at your your costs first and your
Investments second I hope that's not
entirely running against what we ought
to be saying here but Charlotte
I wouldn't disagree I think I would
probably say
you know you consider getting some help
with say a cash flow plan to actually
understand how problematic it actually
is so that sort of follows all know
space with the longer term bit of what
Martin's saying think about what your
outgoings are think about what your
long-term plans would look like and then
you know you can consider actually does
it matter have you actually got enough
there that that you can look through it
and and it's not a problem or is it
potentially something where you need to
maybe cut your cough slightly
differently in order to to manage that
going forward so I think taking that
step back and understanding how much of
a concern it is
um would be a key thing the other thing
I would mention is just bearing in mind
this too shall pass
um you know markets go up and down
inflation goes up and down the
expectation is that by the end of this
year it will feel a lot lower than it
does at the moment so actually making
really knee-jerk reactions right now now
probably isn't sensible you know make
sure it fits with your longer term goals
and objectives
well Charlotte and Martin thank you so
much for the hour you've given us with
some truly insightful thoughts there on
investment management and how we
navigate very difficult times a huge
thank you to our audience for tuning in
from the officer at home a big thanks to
Charles Stanley without them at the
session like this would not be possible
and we hope to see you at another
spectator event soon take care
[Music]
thank you